morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast today it's Wednesday
August 21st Ben hi Claude thank you so
much for joining us am I still a myth
when I'm on this show like rather
frequently like a myth is something that
like you don't see and don't know exists
well that's true that show because
actually I don't know if you guys know
this but Ben was also a guest host on
our patreon last night we did a whole
like dating episode we took questions
about our relationship relationships in
general Thea was here as well in
djibouti barks which is so weird Micah
pick him up for the two the snitch cam
the Theo cam and the snitch the theme
the snitch cam and the CEO cam have
merged as one today cute there is a lot
going on here that was literally a zebra
yeah what was it I have no idea okay I
don't know if everyone can hear but like
very busy day here at toast studios lots
of content being created um thank you so
much for joining me thank you for having
me I have a list of things I want to
talk to you about obviously we're gonna
deliver all the news you need to know
we're also gonna be taking questions
from the YouTube live stream so anything
you've been dying to know about Ben
suffer feel free to leave a comment in
the YouTube livestream I'm watching
right here because I'm really trying to
make youtube happen as opposed to
Facebook I know people think it's like
if they're watching on Facebook they're
not gonna get in trouble at work but I
just think YouTube's a more premium
experience and like the app and then we
can monetize like please just watch on
YouTube is that a thing why would you
get in trouble for watching on YouTube
more than watching on Facebook because
Facebook is like you're more likely to
be doing work on Facebook than you are
on YouTube if you like work in media and
stuff but it's also YouTube's also media
but every business has a Facebook page I
understand you know it seems like a
cop-out you can watch on YouTube looks
less shady
yeah they don't thank you all so much
for being here today we atella Strecker
Monday and Tuesday did you watch I did
you did I did you never watch our show
yeah I didn't watch you're so annoying
okay um um unless I block out this
period of time as you guys know I'm
usually a little bit busy no I don't
have a real job I'm just a little bit
busy yeah well you oh my god Theo keeps
barking he never barks I could hold him
no no he's such a pest on the show yeah
okay sorry so we'll be taking questions
for Beth
if you have any questions for the okay
let him go oh my god he's being sewing
away just let him roam
I guess versus antler maybe he's jealous
kind of a medium content and he wants to
get high say hi to everyone okay we're
back by the way it's literally a family
affair
oh the cameras coming out for a public
affair you guys remember that's on my
god you remember that song over you two
young oh my god people used to think it
was all that all the cameras coming out
for another buffet that's what I thought
it was that was the best Jessica Simpson
song angels instead and through it oh he
offers me protection that was good nice
Wow okay so what other housekeeping
announcements tomorrow we're with TPG
the points guy oh my god I did a post in
the toaster script like asking for like
specific questions for the points guy
like we've never gotten so many like
personal financial questions people
being like oh you know five percent loan
and I need to get my credit back up like
this what's wrong with people
no he's mean what's wrong with people
what's wrong with you you can't you're
not gonna ask personal finance questions
on this show yes he is
the points guys gonna answer everyone's
need like I'm gonna sit here all day
until every question is answered okay
like people trying to go back their loan
after their student ID trying to bail
back their credit after their student
loan debt the points and we'll be
answering it all tomorrow so make sure
you're tuning in there as well and then
tomorrow night we're headed to New
Jersey Hasbrouck Heights for two shows
on the girl with no job dirty jeans tour
there's like seven VIP tickets left to
this last show that's it so head to girl
with no job comm if you haven't gotten
it yet chris christie will be in
attendance and other popular people from
new jersey amazing I want to talk about
something before we really dive deep
it's kind of serious we feel like we
have to do I want to talk about
something sure you jeans okay please
explain yourself
I've asked you multiple times not to
wear those jeans great I like them but
see with the people yo please on YouTube
I'm watching on YouTube please let me
know what you think about Ben's jeans
they're light blue I'm
and what do you like blue white blue big
gashes in the need nope they are ripped
like blue jeans that is it like what I
want to know what people are saying Theo
it's just because they're [ __ ] pasty
we have a show to do okay I know you two
are not understanding we are live okay
so Margo can you oh my god like can you
take this beautiful boy and go outside
with him we have a shower get out oh my
god a bunch of amateurs
I feel like torture I won't even miss
you get out oh my god I'm so wound up
really walking in front of the camera
I'm sorry we need to start again good
morning Milano
okay I feel much more relaxed enough
that Theo's got he's such a pest
he was tough it was tough Jacky hates
when he comes and like I always feel
like she's being mean but she's so right
look how much were dissing how
distracted we are we were distracted and
I don't know what like bloody napkin
chewing like somebody's nose boy back to
your genes I'm not letting you get away
but yeah I'm wearing ripped blue jeans
there is no problem with them okay here
here are some of people's thoughts on
your jeans the holes are a little too
big it's because I'm sitting down the
darker the Jean the better sometimes
someone said did you wreck your
skateboard on your way to the show yes
and that's my job that's actually
hilarious
do they look better now no it's just you
know what it is I can't I can get past
the ripped jeans element it's more the
color cool all right so bright it is and
you know what on the show I'm looking on
the youtubes it's not even doing justice
to the color because it's coming off a
little darker than they actually are
yeah they're trendy whitewash blue jeans
did you get them Paige a very trendy
company oh my god you look great you
look great I know thank you for wearing
them on the show today you're welcome
okay do you've anything else you want to
say that the people before we jump right
in no okay well ladies and gentlemen
without further ado we're a little
delayed because of Theo today
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast did you
know that we added a sound effect know
that sound effects we edit it Wow can't
hear it but everyone else hears it I
know you never watch the show so I want
to let you know an update on our show so
I have a question is this let's make fun
of Ben and tear him to shreds like
hosting with Jackie co-host Jackie
that's so mean for me she comprehends me
yeah actually she does I was actually
surprised because I went I'm not on the
show I rarely watch because I find it
like FOMO Central and I get like angry
being like no my opinion is better than
the person who's in my seat but I did
watch when you were on cuz it was
perfect timing for me to watch on the
plane and it was very good I did still I
really like was getting angry because
like you tell stories that like we
experienced from like your point of view
where I like tell the truth you know I'm
some I'm excited to write some of those
wrongs
no but I was being surprised at how like
Jackie was like letting you just like
she wasn't being tough on you you know
she's letting me chat you got to be
tough his show is chatty let's chat stop
putting up walls okay
Oh would you like a sip of water before
we start I'm great
oh are you gonna be clearing your soda
huh no times I did was I just one throat
clear I just came from Taylor Strucker
who I bronchitis and everyone was
complaining in the podcast cuz she kept
coughing one throat good if you do have
to clear your throat just cover your mic
and if you do have it to clear your
throat don't no I'm good okay so let's
remember the best backstories first is
from the Daily Mail and it goes a little
something like this it's loading Kim
Kardashian and Kanye West have quote one
embryo left and it's a boy as a couple
plants have their fourth child soon so
I'll read you all the details but
actually this rumor started in the
morning toasters Facebook group
obviously we they they freeze so Kim's
third child would be a surrogate oh I
didn't know that because she had an
ectopic pregnancy Oh
Irish a lots of complications with her
was her throat clear no but now you got
it in my head here have some water
I'm trying I'm trying for the people
listening to the podcast like you're
welcome
what's in here seltzer
what does it taste like nothing good
okay well so north and st. we're both
Kim pregnancies Chicago I keep I keep
forgetting that one's name
Chicago is via gestational carrier okay
surrogate mhm and they're saying that
when they like had all their embryos
made they still have one more left
mm-hmm I do it's like the sperm some
people consider it a life mm-hmm but we
won't go to that because it's very
controversial mhm
do you know you don't know I don't think
I do either I do the second it starts
becoming baby right it's like sad white
early it's on the belly yet like it's
not alive no but like it's very
controversial you know what I think we
should stop right where we're at people
like are very upset about this and
honestly you meet you and a new baby at
all stages I don't know enough you know
I know let's do baby it all right there
all right so Kim Kardashian and her
rapper Bo that's a weird way to say
husbands rapper Bo yeah
it's kind of like condescending it's
come on I mean he's like the number like
the most talented like artists of like
his genre and they're referring to him
as a rapper Bo it's all weird and he's
not even like our boyfriend it's her
husband it so many years it's a little
strange they three children together
it's a little weird that's very bizarre
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West because I
respect are reportedly planning on
having a fourth child according to Us
Weekly like totally Us Weekly they don't
know anything I'm not a hundred percent
buying it the web sites insider revealed
that they have one embryo left and that
it's a boy so that would make it two
boys two girls like literally she's so
perfect it's very nice the entrepreneur
and the artist so I guess the
entrepreneur is Kim here and the artist
is Kanye why are they using such weird
words I don't know why they're even
saying that right the entrepreneur and
the artist that literally sounds like
marketing in common that says like Mark
Cuban and Claude Monet yeah Cooper the
artist this is such a weird article very
weird they plan on implanting the last
embryo into a gestational carrier soon
another source for the magazine added
Kim 37 and Kanye are parents in North
five st. too in Chicago seven months
honestly the thing I love about Kim is I
feel like she's like obsessed with her
kids yeah
why when you don't agree no I think
she's a very good mother
don't like get the obsessed with her
kids I think she's obsessed with north
oh you think North is her favorite oh
for sure didn't she the first she's the
first yeah yeah and you feel it I almost
feel like it's the opposite like the
first one like it's like your love pride
and joy and then you keep having new
ones and like you can't remember the
first one you know then that must be how
Olivia feels well you're the oldest yeah
and I don't feel that way but you're a
boy to being the oldest points like I
miss your responsibility in Judaism yes
but like in life also sure what
responsibilities have you taken on is
the oldest man literally all the family
drama sits on my shoulders does it yes
there are family not every single pit of
my family sits right here how so you
feel like no I just need to solve all
problems I'm the problem so it comes to
everyone with every problem is that a
family thing do you think I'd like your
friends do that too interesting I think
it's a family thing I think it's a
family thing too but it's kind of
underrated that you're like the oldest
and Judy isn't it call it the Behar it's
like a very respectful did you feel
special being the before of course like
speaking of before do any of the
Watchers watch the affair how was
Raymond into the canyon the moment of my
death he died right Mitch your daddy and
I made you the only one thing to do and
that's be the way that I am and then
sink in the ocean not yet there's only
one thing to do and that's be the way
that I am and then sneak back into the
sea back into the Oh sink back into the
ocean sink back into the old sink back
into the ocean sink back into the ocean
honestly we were watching we're catching
up so don't spoil anything I'll
literally kill you we're halfway through
apparently the season already ended like
we have the whole thing yeah but we're
on Episode like six and it was mad slow
to start and we were considering not
following through but I had heard
amazing things about it and like the
episode last night really turns it
around it was incredible when cold was
on that like that ranch
those weird ladies having sex with that
girl who like was a part of his room
then he did that whole thing find her
scent in nature it was beautiful it was
such a great episode the reason why I
mentioned the affair that was because
you calling me about [ __ ] yeah I
realize that I think that the writers of
the affair of Jewish because they keep
using very Jewish terms like yeah I use
be sure to use Bashar last night it
always says permit created by hud guide
levy that's totally like a Jewish
Israeli guy yeah no I
there's definitely Jewish undertones to
there are and now if we pointed out to
you'll watch every episode look at that
mindset mm-hmm and you'll be like damn
that's mad Jewish except for like
although like adultery and stuff and
everything else about it and nobody
being Jewish but they're Jewish
undertones who is your favorite
character I know you're gonna say in
there is my favorite character in the
affair yeah wow what a tough question
probably Helen I think actually weak I
knew you liked Vikram that's what I
thought you were gonna say I love Helen
and I feel like she doesn't get enough
like 30 minute segments when they break
it out in school she's the best little
psychotic Allison gives me such anxiety
such a pig wild like mouth area really
bothers me
actually I don't wanna make fun her yeah
good for you you're learning yeah good
for you you're the one who started to
make fun of our girl like you're a boy
if you make fun of a girl took really
not nice you know there's a special
place you know there's a special place
in out for boys who call other girls
that have you ever called her Alf at
know like even behind her back
you call girls fat all the time oh my
god no I do not well meet that yes I do
but I'm just abused you tell me you want
me to motivate you
what's more motivating than being called
fat okay so Kimmy Katya having a fourth
kid but you don't get that vibe from her
that she's like obsessed with being a
mother I feel like it really changed her
no you Joe
no I don't I do I don't get that vibe I
think that she's obsessed with being a
fashion icon right now oh my god I
couldn't disagree with you and everyone
who meets her who like has that like
either like the toasters have like
underground it's crazy
look some of them have like met her like
either like they worked for companies
that Kim hired and they they met her in
passing and all they can say is that
she's the sweetest and there's like a
good mom and all she cares about is
being with her kids which is so funny
that that's what like Kourtney the role
Kourtney's playing on the show you've
been keeping up with the kardashians
slightly I haven't yes what are your
thoughts on the whole debacle between
Kourtney
everyone else I think it's very tough
because we only get bits and pieces
obviously on the show so we can't know
for sure but if Kim actually does have
adequate time to spend with her kids
I think Courtney's being very dramatic
the amount of time that it takes to film
one of those episodes where it launches
once a week does not take up so much
time that she can't still be with her
kids what are the five was it five hours
on a Sunday go to school no that holds a
BA Cole was on a weeknight
so Kim was like I don't want to pull the
kids out of school let's do it after
school no but I'm saying okay so one
weeknight yeah I'm saying it's not the
whole week you know when she still goes
on trips with her boyfriend like
literally for weeks at a time without
the kids but like this one night photo
shoot was the thing that bothered her
yeah it didn't make any sense
it made no sense okay I'm glad you agree
yeah no this is some morning television
news we'd like to stay updated with the
Kathie Lee's in the HOTAS of the world
just to see what our competition is
doing oh uh what are your thoughts on
hotel I don't know I just like Oh
honestly she's a boss but you know
obviously nothing compares to the Cho's
so it's like what people underneath us
are doing it's you're interesting and
you know what megyn kelly is career was
like yes I do she got a show on The
Today Show after being on Fox and
everyone like literally ripped her to
shreds for the first month of her show
now it's good I mean it's not good I
just haven't heard anything no people
stopped ripping her to shreds yes but
this is an article from page six that
says more people are starting to watch
megyn kelly today insiders at NBC's
Meghan Kelly JR quietly celebrating a
modest victory we're told after the long
ailing show began to add some viewers
the much-heralded talk show which airs
during the Today Show has seen
historically low ratings after its
launch in September 2017 but the latest
numbers from Nielsen show host megyn
kelly of 1% from this week last year and
up five percent from the same time last
week it's been steadily climbing said a
source and may not sound like much but
were told that the ratings down are down
all over the TV schedules show insider
see an increase of a positive sign that
the show was gaining momentum a rep
confirmed that the rating the growth in
the ratings school non-politically at
all I [ __ ] hate megyn kelly I hate
when she speaks I think everything that
she says is unbelievably stupid and I
think that her show format is horrible
like I only watched the first week I
watched the first week so if something
has changed viewers please let me guys
but based on the first week she would
talk it
some fluffy news like like we're like
rehire sting some like endangered fruit
and then she'd bring on like five people
to tell such an emotional story like she
combined the fluffiest news with dr.
Phil and she's not dr. Phil and she's
not fluffy news well like she used to
talking about politics great said that
and all of a sudden she's talking about
nothing my issue with her is like how do
you go from being just like a political
like she was in like she was so
political and like so like in it and how
do you just decide you want to go talk
about exotic fruit on it like NBC
because she's a sellout right right she
doesn't give a [ __ ] about politics if
you're gonna have like values it's dead
by them she doesn't have any values we
could also see because she flip flop
values the whole time total like one
morning she was a Republican one morning
she was a Democrat she didn't know what
she was and that's because she just
wants to be on TV total and honestly I
kind of understand it respect her for
that but my issue with the show is like
she gets really good guests and what I
like about the show is that she'll take
guests at the Today Show won't really
take like Housewives and stuff Today
Show takes itself too seriously and only
like the top-tier Housewives get to go
on on Today Show but megyn kelly takes
like some of the lower hanging fruit
which I like but I think the her
interview style is so weird it's like
she doesn't realize that like yes it's
her show but the interview was not about
her I always struggle with people being
like you should have a talk show like do
you know what a talk show requires being
a listener like listening to other
people yeah like she she thinks it's
like all about her yeah so when she's
interviewing the count it's like she's
talking about how she loves a margarita
I like that [ __ ] it's about you totally
that's my problem she doesn't want to
stop talking yeah and I think it's very
different than the Today Show because
the Today Show I don't think has any
viewership issues so they're allowed to
turn down people right they will do
literally anything to get more viewers
on that show so if countess LuAnn
putting a swipe up in Instagram stories
to watch Megyn Kelly's dumb [ __ ] show
is gonna help them with their viewership
I'll I said that's what it is yeah no
but you know it's so interesting that
article says is that TV ratings are down
in general that's definitely true it's
just so crazy no I mean we have alt
alternative streaming methods look at us
do you think we are the reason that TV
ratings are down thousand percent media
like somebody would have been watching
the Today Show and instead they're
watching this yeah I don't know if
someone who watches Today Show also
watches this like seems like they have
different some kind of parallel yeah
yeah no I know you mean but like it's in
a way that we still like respect TV like
getting your own TV show is like the
highest honor I mean while it's on the
way down yeah getting your own web show
should be the highest honor it's true
except TV has built an audience right
like people who that's right so big it's
honor like somebody could just like fart
have a show on TV I didn't have 10
million viewers just by accident just by
access that's drag it's like the
accessibility like if you have a TV show
this show automatically goes to here you
just plug this show right but I think
that like like obviously the goal of
this whole thing is like we're gonna
make it big you know get on a primetime
Network but when you're on TV you lose
the accessibility like people can watch
us at work on their phones or listen on
the train like you can't listen to megyn
kelly you don't I mean it definitely
should not be one or the other
right what's the word agnostic like
where you just are on one agnostic is no
agnostic is it not on you know I want to
be like media agnostic like where you go
back to me on TV because also watch me
on Facebook YouTube podcast whitter
totally that stuff it should be the same
live stream format just on TV fun agile
on iCarly how do we get by the way we
always say that we are iCarly no quick
thing for Nickelodeon icarly wasn't
influencer no be the first yeah it's
unbelievable 15 years ago she thought to
have a web show
then we said why didn't anybody do it
we've said this before we said icarly
was the first influencer it's crazy
she was the beta morning Joseph it's
unbelievable yeah it's unbelievable and
that she's gonna have respect ma'am I
ran to cap cosgrove I mean what they
should have done was they should have
actually live streamed I couldn't but
Wow back in the day they were ahead of
their time yeah and back of the day like
no one was able to be that in tune with
what's necessary but now like if it was
a if it was a TV show about a web show
they would have the web show and have
like digital episodes on their website
so that's what I'm saying you should do
have a TV show with a web show it sounds
like a lot of work and like two shows
you know that's pretty good okay
I picked a sports article for you today
cool because I know how involved you are
in the whole sports community
apparently there's a morning toast
sports group that a lovely lady invited
to yesterday so I will be joining that
group how many Facebook groups are you
in I'm in about like 16 I think - - yeah
are you mean the actual morning show so
I'm in the morning toasters and then I'm
in boyfriend's morning toasters oh I'm
in love with the show sir which is
reserved for significant others of
choice there's only like no no toasters
are actually allowed in it but me and
Jackie moderate it I don't ever post or
anything we just like moderates make
sure like no snitches get in and it is
my favorite group
they don't post frequently enough I
check it like once a week because
there's like a couple new posts a week
it's [ __ ] hysterical it's like this
this is like they're really like
significant other like straight boys
like you cowabunga like just railing on
The Bachelor and us and it's so I have
you even seen that oh my god I've been
telling you I don't know like I get in
sometimes I okay I join a million posts
by the way is this lamp HOT are you HOT
oh my god have some water here oh no I
don't want your fake water that's like
weird seltzer I'm good I was just like
commenting that my neck is like 2,000
degrees I'm sorry hold on I just have to
block someone on YouTube who's bothering
me what do you say no nothing he's just
starting drama okay okay okay so this is
a sports article and before I tell
unlike by Rick before I tell you the
answer I want you to guess it because
Forbes did like a whole list of the
highest paid female athletes of 2018 who
do you believe was number one who was
the highest paid female athlete of 2018
it's such a tough question
probably a soccer player would be my
guess I don't know
so here's the thing Oh Serena Williams
for sure okay so I also thought it would
be Serena Williams um or soccer player
definitely not WNBA well so Sabrina
Williams had a good excuse because she
took a 14 month break after billing in
January 7 7 2017 that she was pregnant
her earnings of 18 million are still
best among female athletes for the third
straight year thanks to win the
endorsement portfolio unmatched among
women in sports so Sabrina Williams is
the highest paid athlete of 2018 and she
didn't even play yeah endorsement ales
great is that so crazy that was pretty
nice that's how like that's what we were
talking on our a story we did yesterday
is the highest paid female actresses and
like number four was Jennifer Aniston
even though home
girl doesn't even work and yes she makes
friends royalty but she's in every
[ __ ] commercial 26 million is from
like Aveeno SmartWater I love and by the
way every commercial she is a fantastic
spokesperson spokesperson really yeah I
just see it and I trust it like I I see
her on the Aveeno and I'm like well
Aveeno do I want her skin on it look
she's just not like yeah fountain of you
know what I mean like yes Aveeno Aveeno
is the wrong one like ice water one is
good and I see her on Emirates I'm like
oh my god oh right I want to fly that's
how she's making bad but that commercial
where she chooses to sit in coach but
not like her sweeten for its class I'm
so stupid
that's weird but I agree with you with
the Aveeno just because she's she's
aging gracefully yes but her skin is
like I want her skin yeah I got like a
young I was like what if pals are should
be a B now she's amazing skin I mean
honestly I should be of you know I have
unbelievable skin do you look at my skin
well you have a beard so I can't see it
look at my skin no if I was a boy I
would legit just like have a beard and
then cover all my pimples I just don't
have pimples ever that's such a lie no
it's not true I get you you dig into
blackheads which are very different
everybody has a blackhead no I can legit
like I could see one right now quick PSA
if I ever have a pimple it's because she
gave it to me by taking her dirty ass
fingernails and going like everybody
sticking the dirt into my pores thus
creating a pimple that she can pop
endless cycle honestly I wish that were
true it is I'm very clean when I clean I
don't even pop your pimples all I ask is
for like five minutes a day on your nose
to get blackheads and you can't even
give me that no because you literally do
it to break my nose you dig and you dig
and you dig yeah dig and you dig and you
dig okay so yes sweetie Williams made 18
million dollars this year like from bed
it's awesome it's awesome
what does she what products do she
endorses chase chase is probably huge
chase we gotta get him with Chum she can
also do whatever she wants she's super
cool your ollie is like a ton him she's
more than a dozen sponsors Nike
intel Audemars Piguet which i think is
logic again
JPMorgan Chase Lincoln cars Gatorade and
beets
by the way she actually could be the
most premium person ever only 16
athletes on the planet made more than
Williams over the past 12 months three
horsemen and she made twice as much so
okay I have like such a sweet spot in my
heart for Serena Williams why I wrote my
final it wasn't like a thesis but it was
the final paper I'd to write in order to
graduate on Serena Williams because it
was a class called human law something
and it was all about like how like
subtle racism exists in in our time and
I wrote this whole paper on slam
Williams because first of all I just
think she's epic like in everyone she is
and like when she's like yell at
everyone like break your tennis racquets
I thought she was even better but like
now that's frowned upon
but I just did so much research on her
and like the way that the media uses um
like adjectives to describe her versus
like Caroline Wozniacki who's like
skinny white blonde and like weighs a
hundred pounds whereas sarena like you
could see the physicality on her because
she's in such great shape but they use
very different words to describe her
like and and her hair and like the New
York Times like I had like four or five
articles where like they were just like
blatantly racist then called her beastly
would they call Caroline Wozniacki
beastly no but look she's a beast
totally but in a good way in a good way
but like to use this there was an
adjective in like a prestigious
newspaper seemed to have underlying
racism all I'm saying yes I mean I
disagree I did I disagree but I got an
a-minus like you can I disagree because
if we are going to bring men and women
onto the same plateau in sports and
compare them I'd call any tennis player
B's oh by the way that's the other thing
it's like she has holds more titles is
more she's the greatest athlete I think
in the world not just a woman that's
just why I can argue the beast yeah but
she doesn't make as much as like the
number-one man tennis player
yeah because Tenten female tennis is not
the same it doesn't have the same market
yes but I by the way I think it has more
like you can you can make it all you
need for like the WNBA and NBA like that
obviously the NBA has way more viewers
but like I think that the women's find
out that you be a US Open and the men's
find out the US Open is just as exciting
like there's not like
don't have I don't have that gender
dynamic that I do with with basketball
okay
I'm such a sporty gal today you're like
a little wrong but it's fine why you
think that men's tennis is regarded more
as like a bigger deal I think every
single male sport is regarded as a
bigger deal not saying that it's right
I'm just saying no but facts facts are
facts
if the women's US Open was not held in
conjunction with the male US Open like
if you weren't going to the event to
watch the man less people would be there
to watch the way my god I totally
disagree okay I agree with you on every
other sport I love watching Serena
Williams she's the only person I'd go I
know you're saying sports is a
male-dominated thing and it has been
forever and like no other leagues like
the WNBA is nowhere close to the NBA
whatever other leagues like the female
soccer is not even close to but you you
are the women's remember that the
women's soccer team in the World Cup won
a couple years ago and they literally
like made a million dollars the men's
team came in like sixteenth and they
literally made like thirty million
dollars like it's so [ __ ] up but I
don't think what I'm saying is that I
don't agree that that is the way it is
in tennis okay I think then this is the
closest one right women's tennis it's
just as exciting just as popular as
men's tennis I know Jesse no but see I
could prove it because I know Serena
Williams I know Maria Sharapova I don't
know any female soccer players I'm not
comparing tennis to other women's sports
no I'm competitive tennis women's tennis
is by far the most popular women's sport
well no gymnastics ojen a success good
yeah but gymnastics happens once every
four years I mean it still goes on
during the four years it's not popular
during the four years they're sitting at
home watching the balance beam on a on a
Tuesday actually they do play it on NBC
sometimes during the day and it's very
exciting like the the trials you know
I'll stick it mhm
no I hear what you're saying I disagree
with you cool but and I think that
Serena Williams making less money than
the number one male tennis player is
complete [ __ ] because not only is
she better than them physically she's
more famous than them she's like the
most famous outfit of all time and now
she's like a power couple but the guy
who invented reddit she's on the cover
of Vogue like come on she's so epic is
she making less money though why is she
making less money then
is it Roger Federer like who's the
number-one male tennis I will tell you a
joke a [ __ ] for sure I don't think so
he's not so marketable hold on let me
check though Jeff better or like is one
of the greatest tennis players of all
time and has his own company apparel
company like Duane Reade on 74th Street
is calling you do you need to pick it up
no uh prescription yeah another reason
why my family's things lie on my
shoulders my family Duane Reade account
he's for whatever reason under my phone
number so when my sister's adderall what
is ready to be picked up hello your
prescriptions ready like no I don't have
a prescription please stop [ __ ]
calling me so Rafael Nadal is the number
one male tennis player and I'm gonna
look up his 2017 earnings okay Serena
Williams made eighteen eighteen in
endorsements oh right cuz I guess she
didn't play this says that he made
twenty so it's kind of similar that's
good by the way he made twenty overall
yeah six million in prize money fourteen
million overall like that then that
means that she wins so I don't want the
hell that articles talking about forbes
has Rafael Nadal at the number 72
like highs earner hey Serena well I'm
sorry I'm sorry I ever that completely
wrong forty million roughly on the doll
but that makes sense from both prize
money and endorsements his career prize
money is a hundred million dollar if
Serena Williams played this year between
prize money and endorsement deals she
probably would've made 40 million so
let's see what she made in 2016 when she
was playing sure well I'm really
invested in this yeah it's a little long
so let's look it up and then okay sorry
sorry no I just I really want justice
for Serena Williams here's justice for
her know there's she kills it okay 2016
84 yeah
come on it should be 84 million in
career prize money I know that's overall
she's more than a dozen corporate
partners honestly like at this point
it's like how can you even complain cuz
she's so damn rich but damn rich I'm
just killing it she's don't be sad for
her be sad for Venus her twin sister
that played this year and definitely
didn't make even close to the amount of
money and endorsements it's really nice
that Venus brought her up that Serena
still plays doubles with Venus it's very
nice if Serena got like a better partner
they could like win
every time totally she's really doing it
as like a favor because like they're
sisters totally do you remember when did
you member those commercials Serena
Williams had a fragrance and it was
called an heiress because of its Serena
backwards and the commercial will be
like in Harris and they they flip around
Serena no wow that's cool yeah I think
it's a fragrance or like a clothing line
and I remember next story is from
BuzzFeed which I hate to do because I
literally hate BuzzFeed and we've never
spoken we've never taken a story from
them but they had a really good like
article on this so it looks like Lauren
Jauregui just responded to the Tiffany
Haddish with harmony shade at the VMAs
so you may know Lauren Reggie as one of
the fifth slash fourth of the girl group
fifth harmony I've never heard of her
you don't know her I know fit harmony
she's this one she was on um I was
really pretty sure maybe I do okay okay
yeah she was like they say I would say
she's the second most talented in the
group and Tiffany Haddish yeah I love
her so you may also know her as not
being afraid to speak her mind she's
like a big social advocate and she
called out a journalist for trying to
start drama between the group and
Camilla previously so she's known for
being like you know today yeah but like
in a good way you know other people said
oh I understand she called that a
reporter who was trying to start your
day Oh cold add or repeat the story
Borna Reggie is at Harmony yes and she's
in Taurus and known for being outspoken
on social media especially to like
thirst monsters who try to start like
faith harmony drop got it I thought you
meant people with in fifth harmony
trying to start drama like she was the
one that was like breaking up the group
so you know that Camila Cabello was a
member of Cathar me yes so great which
by the way selfish so there was a
dramatic event at the VMAs on Monday
night when Tiffany Haddish threw some
shade in the direction of disharmony
fifth harmony wasn't there Camilla was
there and won a bunch of awards and was
not it was like Camilla's night you know
yep so she was like this is what Tiffany
I said Camilla
could look up a I was here chained she's
nominated for five whatever so to all
you watching at home - harmony yeah it
was shot day and like I was there and it
was like pretty awkward Wow um and then
it was even more awkward because when
Nicki Minaj's won an award a couple like
minutes later she got up on stage and
she was like Tiffany don't come for my
girl my [ __ ] normani so there was just
drama all around yeah I know but very
good for normani being boys with Nicki
I know born has weighed in on the
situation and she's placing herself
firmly above the
so she tweeted waiting for the day when
supports supporting one successful job
woman does not mean insult to other
successful job women there was energy
and space for all of us to beautifully
coexist and bless the world with our
individual truths stories and talents
mm-hmm it's true
and then obviously people are giving her
[ __ ] and she wrote again incredible even
a tweet about uplifting others can be
misconstrued a shade I give up y'all
talk all the [ __ ] you want so basically
what she was trying to say and honestly
I thought it was a weird tweet because
as far as I know her and Camilla are not
on good terms but basically what she was
saying is like you don't have to bring
us down to support me like we can all be
great I mean they can't but sure well
they aren't but they could they could
but they're not hypothetically if
Camilla was still with the harmony
harmony this harmony was destined for
bad things because as someone who
watched them on fit on x-factor
did you watch I expect her I was gonna
ask which show it was we started dating
like around that I watched it I remember
x-factor being like a huge part of my
life and I was planning on auditioning
but then I watched x-factor they
cancelled the American one but it was
always odd to me because it almost
seemed like Camilla fell through the
cracks and then got this chance to be in
a group and she was so much better than
them at such a young age and like every
time they performed every time Camilla
would sing like the audience went wild
and they gave her all the solos and she
started the songs and she ended the
songs like it was really the the Camilla
show so she really never should have
been in pathar me to begin with because
I think all the other girls are equally
talented and they would have been great
as a foursome without her but they
probably wouldn't have been and that's
where I was gonna say it's the same
thing as one direction it's the same
thing as all of these groups that come
up through these shows American Idol
x-factor voice whatever it may be they
need that one pillar to help carry them
to the next round
I think is the one direction pillar
Harry Styles I see I agree with you but
now the world doesn't agree with you
what does that mean the world like and I
kind of agree with everyone like Harry's
my favorite but I think all five of them
together we're great together
I completely agree not one of them was
more talented than the other I don't
know more less guy I don't agree I don't
agree but I don't think I think one
direction would have been so really
successful if Harry hadn't been in it
not what it was I mean they had they had
a chance to be did you see that they put
a tour date up on stuff like today you
showed me this will you go with me of
course
you know we already gone in Australia
sure it's just one show rough flight I
know yeah you paying for up
so yes so Lauren Reggie is not here for
the drama of people pitting women
against other women and I couldn't agree
more except I do pit women against other
women when it's Angelina Jolie I'm not
including cuz like I love that story
from this week but in the case of Camila
bursa Harmonizers who do you take it's
very tough if the Harmonizers were truly
dragging her down then you gotta you got
to do what you got to do when she was in
fifth harmony she was my absolute
favorite and I wanted justice for cuz I
think she deserved a solo career and
when she left I was like proud of her
and cuz it couldn't have been easy to
walk away from really successful girl
band but if I was a member of fifth
harmony I'd be pissed as [ __ ] yeah me
too but why can't you be like I just
never understood the idea of turning
something into a solo career like why
can't she just take like say okay
instead of me taking my solo career I'm
just gonna take 60% of the money and
then you guys split the other ten tenten
tenten this is thing I don't know why
you can't be a part of a group and have
a solo career so towards the end of her
time with fifth harmony I'd released bad
things with Machine Gun Kelly which was
like the best song ever and it was just
her she was on a couple songs like
without them Lauren will her egg he was
on an Aoki song like I don't know why
you can't do both I guess because then
you're vegans to launch like a solo
career Lee I don't need that no because
then you're putting your best foot into
your solo work because that's gonna make
you more money right it's very difficult
I'm just saying if Beyonce stayed with
Destiny's Child and just let Destiny's
Child be like her backup singers it
would in the same career oh my god you
are so wrong why if you push the the
star to the forefront what's the
difference well because you can't this
Beyonce can't be compared because she's
like an anomaly and she's like the most
talented woman alive and she was never
meant to be in the group Camila Cabello
is no be Johnson no I'm just comparing
groups you ever know but you can't
compare because like Beyonce was so
clearly and Destiny's Child was a great
springboard for her but like she was so
meant to be like the Queen of the
Universe because she's so gifted even
the Queen of the Universe still has
backup singers
yeah but Michelle Williams and Kelly
Rowland we're not gonna be backup
singers they were celebrities at the
time like they were never gonna be okay
with me ever see Dreamgirls
yes but okay it's not okay with being
pushed it back okay you got so headed
yeah what's your favorite song some team
girls remember I don't remember anything
I have amnesia me too it's contagious
like name me songs from dream girls we
are dreaming girls boys will make no oh
I know I know this one and now I have to
sing the whole song because you asked
it's 11:11 make a wish listen to the
sound from deep within it's only
beginning to find release oh I'm
screaming out and my dreams will be
heard they will not be pushed aside and
turned into your own all cause you won't
listen I am alone at a crossroads I'm
not at home in my own home and I've
tried to tried say what's on my mind you
should have known oh now I'm done
believing you you don't know what I'm
feeling I'm more than what you made of
me I followed the voice you think you
gave to me
but now I've gotta find my that was very
good
do you know that song I do honestly for
anyone watching who's a big Beyonce fan
I'm sure you already know this but
honestly go to youtube and watch her
sing that song in her documentary on HBO
in the car right before she like goes to
see Oprah or something and oh my god
she's like in the car just practicing
like her laptop is in her lap and she's
just like practicing one last time and
literally it's the best I've heard
anyone sing in my whole life
really and it's in the car i watch yeah
you should watch it Oh Camilla you know
you can't use me ounce as an example
because like it's just it's so different
okay now wasn't what I meant
I wasn't pinning them against each other
but yes yes I do you think that Camilla
was supremely talented but like as a
solo artist she's fine okay and as a
performer she's not so great they got
walking anyway yeah actually they had
Simon Cowell anyone I need a towel
that's what I'm saying they they got
lucky like with that these shows totally
like it Beyonce came up with no show
right all on her own
by the way the luckiest just got to say
it Bieber totally even though that whole
thing was kind of orchestrated it wasn't
really like that YouTube video that he
was discovered on like it was all kind
of like a setup really yeah that was
like it came out like years later like
Usher was like a part of like the setup
with Scooter Braun oh and they want to
make it seem like it was just like
native YouTube thing interesting it was
a kind of pre-planned I believe interest
do you remember those videos of course
oh my god we I swear at the time what
was that song one you like a dream come
true to just wanna be with you three
girl it's plain to see that you're the
only one for me and for I repeat step I
know the song I don't remember let's
move on who's your favorite of all time
favorite artist of all time that's
really tough I don't know great answer I
don't know okay there's our final story
before we launch into some questions for
Ben so there's so many different ones if
you're watching on YouTube
feel free to flood the comments with
questions for Ben so that
to think of anything post Malone's plane
lands safely after two tires blow during
takeoff so did you hear about this yes
it was happening all day and like I kept
checking back to me like oh it landed
and like literally hours went by and he
didn't land yeah how scary terrifying
basically he took off on his private
plane after the VMAs from Teterboro and
while he was in the air two of their
tires like blue and they were circling
around like trying to land in like
Boston they couldn't land how do tires
blow I don't even know that airplanes
had tires yeah that's what you land on
what do you mean you ain't on wheels oh
so I guess that's why they couldn't land
can't land because there's nothing to
land on oh [ __ ] yeah I don't know that's
why every single plane should also have
the option to be a seaplane yeah oh
that's so true so you like Sully yeah so
post Mo's private plane has made a safe
landing at the Stewart Airport in New
York what the hell is that no idea but
she is too poor to notice footage posted
on social media shows that the rapper
has safely evacuated the plane and is
taking the first responders talking with
first responders at the airport
totally like only super-rich people know
it's - were terrible no idea Malone's
rap tells a that everyone landed safe
and then when he landed he tweeted I
landed guys thank you for your prayers
because people were like freaking out
like they thought he was gonna die can't
believe how many people wish death on me
on this website [ __ ] you but not today I
saw this so means show me it's like you
didn't post Malone has feelings it's
wild it's also wild that he is checking
those comments yeah I don't know you're
too cool bro circling for two hours and
he definitely had Wi-Fi so nothing else
to write but read mean things about him
honestly happens to the best of us I
know but what someone explained to me in
the comments thankfully is that they
were circling up there getting rid of
all their fuel mm-hmm so if they did
accidentally like cret like a crash or
something the fuel would set on fire
interesting so they had to get rid of
all the fuel so that at least impact got
it we've so many smart mechanics in our
toasters group well two things one I
love post Malone so I've always loved
his music and we've been like groupies
of his yeah we haven't been to a couple
shows up in the backstage I tried to
like read become a groupie they weren't
having it he's way too famous I used to
be we got him like right before his peak
and like we were still cool with all of
our pictures but then he is like like a
real management now and like the same
manager the manager says it takes me
back lies Dre London to him look I saw
this one over we'll get him back let's
go get him back let's bring on the show
let's prank-call him we should totally
oh my god Myanmar
now that Myanmar girl like I've been
sending so much time in like hotel rooms
during my shows that we're so bored
we've been prank-calling people oh my
god and I did the most epic prank call
on Seth our manager oh my god first of
all so I couldn't believe he didn't know
how my voice was like so not and bye
they call me from a restricted number
it's like the surefire way to tell
people it's a prank yeah you should call
from the hotel no oh I was going to but
they charge you for like local calls in
hotel room oh no I mean that's only like
a cheap hotel no all hotels that's
impossible so wait I mean it was a
double tree so like it was definitely
but so I called from Marlo's phone
because he doesn't have her number so it
looks like a regular number and so I
called and I was pretending to be a
delivery man downstairs at his office
I'm like I knew his office but I never
go far like hello I'm downstairs and I'm
like he said can you bring it upstair so
my nose a big package someone has to
come down and get it and he was like
literally hanging up on me and I was
like oh stupid pickup and I was like a
litter it was so funny that his
assistant ended up going downstairs
looking for my dad and then I called him
back and it knows me but it was so
everybody say what is better he was so
mad at me what is better what is a
better feeling than a successful prank
call no successful pranks are great
remember when we print a lily in
Atlantic City
yes what was my name Maryland Maryland I
don't remember but that escalated really
quickly you don't know when to stop no
prank me and Olivia and Ben we're in
Atlantic City we had two rooms next to
each other
I mean Olivia had gotten into a big
fight and she like screamed at me in her
room and I was like oh my god you're
such a [ __ ] and I like stormed out and
then I went back to my room and prank
call to her room and pretended to be
because if you want to call a hotel room
in your hotel it's free I pretended to
be someone from downstairs that security
was concerned about all the noise and
that police were being sent up and she
got so freaked out she came knocking on
her door it's just like security keeps
calling me and every time she would
leave our room I would call her again
I still know how she didn't know oh my
god someone said dray London was on the
flight he was Instagram story yeah you
should text and be like hey make sure
you're okay that's a good way people
love when you're concerned for them
whatever Dre if you're watching this hit
me up yes he's definitely watching this
I'm he had a traumatic event last night
he's totally waking up this morning I'm
watching the morning toast there it's a
media mention totally and I might get it
what I was saying yesterday really nice
guy what I was saying yesterday -
Taylor's tracker which just furthers my
point is that this show like it's like a
s'more like a small startup whatever we
know millions of people watching but
this show has legs like if you say
something on
about someone it gets back to them nine
times out of ten I was just telling her
like be warned and then once I said that
something I said yesterday got back to
me and I don't remember how what was it
I don't remember I was a bad thing
it wasn't bad because I would have a pin
about and I would definitely remember it
but I don't remember what it was but it
was something just be careful what you
say
cool speaking of by the way my interview
with Taylor's trekker
it's gonna be up I think it may be
already up or up at some time soon on
taste of Taylor podcast and it's really
good a lot of you been wanting me to
answer some of these questions for a
long time so feel free to go listen to
it I'll beep a couple more minutes so I
just don't we chat you know you're me
and you I'll take some questions from
the YouTube live stream so if you have
any questions for Ben make sure to uh
you concerned about your belly no why
did you just are you concerned about my
belly not at all babe you you like
always do that you move your shirt and
you like readjust when you think your
belly looks big no just just
repositioning okay I'm gonna take some
questions
starting now ready would you rather I
love would you rather xand the toasters
always come up with crazy ones would you
rather be sweating no matter how cold it
was or always be hungry no matter how
much you eat Wow Wow hungry I think so
too there's literally nothing worse
being sweaty than being sweaty you can't
sleep yeah work I think I would rather
be sweaty than hungry I mean hungry than
sweaty and like I feel like hunger as a
feeling like if you get used to it but
you can live with it okay so looking at
Cobo is hungry but she lives with it
it's a terrible feeling that you can
fall asleep when you're hungry your
stomach doesn't like keep you up because
you're sometimes actually it does keep
you up but you're not a sweaty me it
doesn't sweating I can't sleep um do you
like to see music's ass do you like
country music
I like it now I do and and I like some
of it I don't like the same type of
countries you like I don't like I'm
trying to think of like a good one that
I really hate oh my god okay yeah I'm
just not like a big deep country guy
okay I don't know did you love Lou Combs
though as I'm saying surface lyrics
okay the old thing that I said this is
the greatest story it's true but and
we've told you before but we have like
tons of new viewers who might not have
heard it this is my favorite story I
think maybe ever but it's true I stand
by everything that I said
totally so we were in
show me we're on like a media trip with
like a couple other like food bloggers
like um writers and it was like a whole
Nashville trip where like they took us
to like distilleries they took us to
restaurants and like it was just our
jobs like document yep
and it was we were like the youngest
people there everyone there was like
super old and boring and like not
interested in hanging yeah but that's
like we went out the itinerary every
night like ended at 8:00 and then it had
like optional going out to the bars like
me and them were the only people who
went and we like made the staff come
with us it was so annoying so we were in
a cab with like five or six people it
was a big cab going from one restaurant
to another and we're just in the car and
like no one we weren't like meshing well
with the group no they didn't I I kept
trying to start conversation each other
for years and they'd like travel
together and we were like the new bunch
of losers so we nee and like so not fun
yeah so we were just like making
conversation we were talking about like
country music if you like country music
Ben was sitting in the front of the cab
so you were already like displaced in
terms of like not really being included
in the conversation and the conversation
oh that kind of ended we were like over
like we were talking about if you like
country music what kind of culture music
and the conversation pretty much ended
and you chimed in one last time and said
something and you said which was what
you said was weird but that how everyone
else like totally dissed her giardiniera
was even weirder you were like the
conversation was over we were talking
about country music like you were like
you know I really like how like country
music is like it's not just like surface
lyrics like there's just more to it I
was saying that there are some songs
I'll explain what I meant there but
after I said that the whole car went
silent
nobody responded no one not only like
dude what'd you say like not make sense
well they were just being rude and like
not answer so rude and it was so awkward
and it was so funny and what did you say
exactly what I mean is that there are
like there's your Sam hunts there's your
even what's-his-name that we just saw
who comes Lou Combs is great other
people who we just saw born Elena is
normally okay well not Jason Aldean okay
and that's what I'm trying to say okay
there's a difference between like and I
call it pop country yes but like where I
just think he goes a little bit deeper
in terms of the lyrics as opposed to
like I went outside and I picked up a
beer and then I saw a bear in the
distance and he made my fear my life
really popular country artists who don't
write songs like Luke Bryan like his
songs are like really stupid and fake
yes that's what I'm saying and those are
surface surface lyrics like where you
talk about going to the store and
picking up a car or going to the store
writing a whole album about like her dad
being alcohol emotional exactly I know
what you were saying
Lera you phrased it so weird like what
are surface sir sir fix lyrics are
lyrics that don't go dan why do you say
lyrics surface lyrics you know lyric
lyrics lyrics no yes lyrics that's like
when you say we're too many times it
starts to sound we know lyrics what is
your favorite episode of friends and do
an impression for bonus points what's my
favorite episode of friends I'm the
holiday armadillo boss besides like what
the [ __ ] is a holiday armadillo honestly
who is your favorite character yes
saraghina that's a controversial answer
like there are people who either like
stan ross like we do or [ __ ] hate him
and what she wasn't on the show i love
love love love love rom thank you i
think he's not only the funniest
character but he's the best actor and a
close second is Phoebe me too but
sometimes like her a stick I like stupid
no her six funny I'll rank it Ross
mmm-hmm Phoebe Joey
hmm Ross Phoebe Rachel no no no Ross Shh
okay sorry I just want to agree with you
Ross Phoebe Joey Chandler Rachel Monica
Monica the bottom mine's Ross Phoebe
Chandler Joey
Rachel Monica sometimes Chandler's [ __ ]
goes it's terrible to know but honestly
like a lot of it says very funny you
know what it is so it's that I think
that Phoebe Rachel Phoebe Ross and
Chandler are the best actors also yes
like I was believing it like that I
wasn't believing that Jennifer Aniston
was like Rachel Green do you know I mean
she was just Jennifer Aniston like she's
not an amazing actor but the the top two
that aren't even on the show obviously
Alec Baldwin Oh Parker Parker
unbelievable
Meza peak what sounds like a magical
place ooh
we're driving aces bow-wow old friend
bow-wow that episode was incredible and
the one where Phoebe sets Rachel up with
the guy that literally wants to kill
himself what's that actor's name he
always plays the same character he's so
sad and so funny he's so fat cracks me
up
um this is the weirdest question but I
kind of want to answer it because just
cuz the way she wrote it was really
weird is it morbid yes no I don't
divorce what what's wrong with all of
you do you fear it before getting
married you prepare your mind for a
potential divorce or just so you know
you're gonna be happy forever
no you I I'm a true believer that you
know if you're gonna get divorced
there's some inkling in the back your
head like maybe I shouldn't do this
no I couldn't agree more um how tall are
you I'm actually gonna make a quick
other controversial statement that guy's
name is Rob Schneider no it's not not
that's the guy Adam Sandler yeah that's
not him Rob Schneider is awesome though
love him if you get a prenup you're
gonna get a divorce I want to know the
rates on people that get prenups
directly correlating to divorce because
if you need to think about protecting
yourself financially that financials are
more important than love than you're in
a lot of trouble that's a cute answer
and I love this question because it has
a reference to my favorite movie
would you rather only drink water for
the rest of your life or be able to
drink anything you want but whatever
you're drinking has like a little bit of
pee in it well the pee make me sick no
it it's night it has nitrates it's good
for you pee but everything will be like
a little yellow no a little bit of pee
is different you won't taste it it's
like soup no you won't taste it but
they'll be color which by the way can be
talked about soup after this okay
I love water so I'm down for water if
there's enough pee that you don't taste
it down for pee whatever
talking about soup I drink drink eat
what did you at soup consume that's a
great question you eat soup but a long
aren't you had a soup you have soup all
right I have a lot of soup i order soup
everywhere I go he does and sometimes I
think you know what they're making this
in a
huge pot and the chef could have just
dipped his boot in it yes the same way
that he could have put it to pee right
like soon and I never would know yes
soup is made for the masses even like a
fancy restaurant they're not making a
bowl of soup like fresh so if you put
like a little bit of urine in it nobody
would ever know how scary is that
thought or like a drop of blood do you
remember when I forget what Water
Company it was but they had to drain
like six thousand tons of water because
one of the employees peed in it but like
in reality it like didn't really make a
difference because it was like one cup
of urine in like 6,000 tons of water but
they had to get rid of all of it still
vile how crazy is that what an [ __ ]
um how old are you 26 I can never
remember recently 26 yeah not so recent
anymore who's your favorite athlete and
who do you think is the greatest athlete
of all time there it's it's very it's
really really tough who's my favorite
athletes probably Tiger Woods what news
to me I know the if no I have anybody
there's a sports fan this week but he's
gonna eat him athletes are gonna cheat I
can't talk about this anymore time it
doesn't make any sense
unless you are even so I vote for LeBron
James on the show and everybody told me
that he cheats yeah so I don't know what
to say anymore if you're an athlete and
you're married to an athlete you have to
understand that you're away from each
other half the year and it is what it is
like athletes cheat men cheat women
cheat athletes cheat if they're an
athlete why I don't know it's sad sees
everything Tiger Woods is your favorite
outside of littering no he's he's super
super I mean he's he's the greatest
califor of all time and at the age of 40
has now made a full comeback after being
destroyed in the media for being a drug
addict having the thing with his wife
having two surgeries and is now back to
top of the world he's just very very
impressive Kobe Bryant is my favorite
basketball player unbelievably
impressive rapist I love Cole of Shaq is
not a rapist Ben I'm just because the
Jerry said he didn't do it doesn't mean
he's not a rapist he's not a rapist Shaq
Shaq
I love Shaq
is the greatest person of all time of
all time because he's so not
controversial it's so rare for someone
not to be contraband I've never heard
him being a cheater
no me neither I'm sure he does that is
he what does is he married
yes he's divorced I think maybe he's
divorced she's really short to look up a
picture that is so funny oh my god um
okay wait this is a maybe there was a
weird question did you love the
University of Cincinnati when you
visited have you ever been to the
University I had a I had a panel at
University of Cincinnati you did yeah
and pitches we're not going into my day
job nibble woods I went like it no
Cincinnati [ __ ] how did it have know
that I didn't because Ashlee Falk
probably saw mainstream stories oh yeah
and you like not remembering that I went
to Cincinnati is it quite rude
where's Cincinnati Ohio I don't yes the
the University of Cincinnati was
actually quite nice was it yeah the
building especially that I was in which
was the football stadium was lovely okay
um that guy from Friends is named Jon
Lovitz love him sorry I'm I'm reading um
so you ate a hair in your food last week
so obviously drinking a drop of pee
wouldn't be a big deal for you but see I
didn't know that I was eating the hair
that's real it's a more of a mental
thing I guess completely mental this is
a great would you rather would you
rather change genders every time you
sneeze or not be able to distinguish
between a muffin and a baby what the
[ __ ] a hundred percent change genders
every time I sneeze totally because what
if I accidentally bite into a baby right
that's the point well I guess you can
kind of control your sneeze like if you
don't want to sneeze you can kind of get
rid of it sometimes you could limit
being a sick question but you know what
all you have to do is sneeze in twos as
most people do but then you're back to
your dinner when do I find out that the
muffin is the baby like if I bite very
softly and don't like you know yes who
is your favorite cast member of Jersey
Shore mm-hmm Pauly D how many kids do
you want to have but I love Vinny how
many kids do what I have but Pauly D is
more fun
on the show how many kids you want to
have but in real life right now like of
any mini and me or but on the show when
I used to watch Pauly D was just like
legend bro yeah who how many kids you
won't have as many healthy ones as I can
5 do you and as many as I can
give enough love to that they're all
nurtured I think that when you start
unlimited amounts of love no I think
that when you start to get up into the
numbers one kid always feels like an
outcast and I don't like that if I learn
from Cheaper by the Dozen too many kids
well mean something I definitely agree
that a dozen kids is too much I think
fathers does the same thing okay I think
3 to 4 is a nice number do you think Oh
J did it [ __ ] yeah what does that mean
no it's just a question someone asked
because there are people who don't get
well those people are nuts someone made
a good point about the baby muffin thing
what just don't need a muffin oh that's
sure baby muffin what is your favorite
thing about Claudia is that actually a
question or that's something that you
just made up no I said someone named Oh
Taylor Owen cop commented it thank you
tell her my favorite thing about Claudia
I mean you really shouldn't have to
think that hard I mean I said like a
whole Megillah on the last show when you
weren't here about the things that I
loved about you okay and and your
confidence rubbing off on other people
so I'm trying to think of a more
creative answer that was nice I actually
remember but that's it that she exudes
such that you exude such confidence and
it rubs off on other people um would you
where would you relocate if we had to
like in Miami done the states Miami just
a little hot I love Miami I'll tell you
five reasons why I love Miami one food
is delicious to night life is delicious
nightlife is great yes here at 11 it's
delicious
three weather unbelievable income tax
zero and with having no income tax the
real estate is dirt cheap yeah we it's a
huge win the only problem for me is the
heat so literally you get to have double
the money when you leave New York and
you get to spend half the rent
we'd be Kings we
Kings would you ever do a reality show
like yes yeah cheating could be good on
it yeah so fun
you don't want one that's the only
reason I have it yeah just so you all
know we could have had one by now she
doesn't want one when Claudia becomes
the new beyoncé to do to her amazing
vocals will you drop everything and tour
with her great question Ashley
well I drop everything into earth her no
because if Claudia was making a hundred
million dollars a year she would still
be on my ass about making $100 a year
100 million dollars a year which is
another thing that I love about you that
regardless you always keep me motivated
I love you yes I think we're supposed to
do dear toasters today but we're already
a little late and do one of them I like
this you do yeah so dear Joe so we
started like five minutes late a couple
technical difficulties we started a line
we did yeah a third thing we started
around a minute late actually this is a
good one so I want to do this one you
think okay but it seemed like so long
ago so long I was so wound up in the
beginning of the show I'm so relaxed so
dear toasters is our advice segment that
we do every Wednesday you can email to
your toasters at gmail.com if you have
anything you want help with we get a lot
of relationship questions friendship
questions really pretty much anything
and this one is a wild you're gonna die
all anonymously by the way so if you
have a like a boyfriend trouble how many
were doing - just one this one's really
good I think you'll have it hilarious
hey my boyfriend of almost a year now
recently told me out of the blue that
after college he donated his sperm a few
times for some extra cash he was not
like struggling for money but just
thought it would be nice to have some
extra money is that like weird I feel
super weird about it everything else in
our relationship is amazing and we get
along great but I just can't get over
how this one weird thing he did are my
feelings validated if we ever have kids
I wonder if I would feel weird knowing
that they have half siblings out in the
world that they don't know Thanks so so
so weird so weird it's such a nice thing
to do but don't donate your sperm if you
plan on having kids of your own there
are plenty of there are plenty of men
out there I'd have healthy sperm and no
wife and no children I think they
I don't think you you can't do both I
just think if you're in a relationship
with someone that you tell them before a
year in no you can't do both because I
don't like if my if my sperm goes into
another woman's body that is my son
excuse me I guess it depends on how I
guess it depends on how emotionally
detached you are but I don't know your
son I don't know what the what the rules
are like if you're a baby born out of
sperm donor do you ever get to contact
your dad I don't think so I think you do
it and it's like you're gone forever
you can always find there's always a way
find well you know Mike in the CIA the
toasters Intelligence Agency where it's
like the salutes live and they like
investigate stuff it's so crazy um they
were able to connect a girl with her
birth family that's wild
she was adopted it's not amazing
unbelievable well I think it's more of a
red flag that the guy waited here no not
that he waited a year that's such a
tough thing to tell someone it's more of
a red flag that he is just so what I
need a couple extra bucks let me donate
my sperm like that is like a really
right here so whit like free willy-nilly
with your sperm it makes me question
that's a good point like him is like a
person him as a person and wanting to
have his own kid he's like what she says
it's like he wasn't really struggling
for money like if you're in the bind and
you need cash like I kind of understand
you're doing it don't eat one he just
voted what do you don't get my hair no
you can be like a part of a medical
study but those two things stick like a
year sperm you get good cash yeah but
what she said is like he just wanted
extra cash he just he wasn't like
struggling so like if you're in a
situation or if you're doing it because
like you have you want to help like if
you have good intentions like that's
awesome
but the most most people who I think
donate sperm aren't doing it because
they like want to help women have kids
you know no but even if you want like I
don't know I just I just feel like it it
says that you're so emotionally detached
from your own sperm that you won't care
what happens to that child that it says
something about the person right I don't
know you're kind of going up in the team
you know but what this girl's asking is
like are my feelings of being feeling
weird justified 100% disease we're very
on 100% justified
it's weird yeah what if you just like
told me like I have a son yeah it would
be weird because you have a son like I
don't care like
right but what you want to comment is
that you usually cannot contact the
person that donates sperm or eggs it
would be very difficult to obtain those
records so for the most part you never
if you're a child of like a sperm or an
egg donor you pretty much never meet
that parent yeah and how are you a human
being knowing that you have kin in the
world and never meeting them I know did
you ever see that movie delivery man
with Vince Vaughn I don't know he
donated sperm like literally seven
million times and then like all the kids
found him concept for a movie I never
saw D that is oh so you haven't seen a
movie even never seen yeah but like it's
relatable cuz like that's what we're
talking about or whatever so I did today
I announced the pre-sale so if you're a
patreon member not only do you get
access to our amazing extra episodes
which we did one last night you also get
presale for the merch for tickets and
the I put up pre-sale for my shows in
Atlanta and Albany so if you don't have
patron you'll get it Friday morning but
might be sold out I don't know and yeah
the merch is merch is coming out with
the 27th that's next Wednesday I'm so
[ __ ] really cool I I like we didn't
order huge quantities cuz you never want
to order a million things and then like
nobody buys that you have to be
conservative um but like I have a
feeling it's gonna sell out because
people are like really excited about it
and I'm really excited about it and it's
not like dumb t-shirts and hats like
it's cute ass [ __ ] also when is your
Atlanta show I don't know but is it on
the website
no okay because well it's impressive but
it's in October mm I think so hopefully
the Falcons are at home and if anybody
here is listening and you happen to have
a box to the Falcons invite us and we'll
come yeah we'll come will come will come
or front-row Sox is way better dies
football front row is so over is there
anything else you want to plug before we
leave no unfortunately I still have
nothing to plug my podcast is coming
eventually it's gonna eventually and you
guys are gonna love it
but until then legal man so yes presale
for Albany in Atlanta starts today
public open on Friday DC show sold out
but we added a second one I will be
giving a link to the public very soon
and Jersey I'm coming tomorrow Chris
Christie is gonna be there as well and
each one to like resurface that joke you
know it was a good joke and then also
what I'm really excited about is my
my interview with tailors trekker that
aired on her show which is a subscriber
subscriber subscriber base show is gonna
be available for free on the taste of
tea our podcast today so make sure you
check that out I would literally love to
hear your feedback even I know I don't
have to tell you guys that I got a
message today it was like a full-power
graph one message she was like do you
guys like a viewer feedback and then
could get gave me the feedback before I
even what if I said no like you know
totally it was so funny and it was like
not a nice feedback but I love you guys
thank you so much for being here
tomorrow we're with TPG so make sure
you're if you're in the toasters group
to go into that thread and ask your
questions because he's gonna be getting
I'm literally gonna rush through the
fast live stories with him and devote
like 45 minutes to just like it is yeah
is it possible that anybody watching the
show does not follow a boy with no job
it's very rare but please go away go
that's it just if you don't follow boy
with no job on Instagram you should it's
me you'll see a bunch of my omelette
stalee me talking about different Kido
regimens that I use to lose weight the
occasional meme that will make you laugh
and pictures of my dog and my wife job
and about wife my BOB but I'll get mo
off argh you guys thank you so much for
tuning in make sure you're following the
morning trust Facebook Instagram YouTube
Twitter all that stuff at the morning
toast we're back tomorrow with the TPG
and then we're off on Friday so don't
forget yeah thanks toodaloo
[ __ ]
you